you know just a good old-fashioned
18-hour day
redeye d-roc Boston
I'm still on that ice house always wins
hey scary
really well how are you good man I just
want to call you for five minutes and
see how you're doing just want to check
in hearing good things we didn't get a
chance to really sit down and talk with
the transition from new business to this
account side and just wanted you to have
a sense of like how much I thought this
would like I'm very but I'm much more
bought into the up side of your career
than I've been able to communicate to
you and I wanted to take a few minutes
and tell you that I just think you're an
unbelievable kid with outrageous levels
of talent and want you to keep me close
if you need me in any way I'm a much
bigger cheerleader and and kind of
architect of your career behind the
scenes that I think you know and I
wanted I wanted to kind of gift you that
knowledge awesome brother have a great
day
right
you know I don't I don't know I don't
understand why leaders don't understand
I mean how long was that call I don't I
don't and I never will understand why
leaders don't understand that a 3-minute
call can create so much upside for the
individual on the other side of the call
you as a leader and and most of all
which is always my first priority the
logo at hand and so you know people
always say things like it blows me away
Gary how much time you have to engage
with your fans on social people we say I
can't believe you you take those five
minutes to say hello what people don't
see as much and what dailyvee allows me
to do is you know this three-minute call
three minutes hundred eighty seconds
could be the difference between this
individual being with us for 10 to 15
years and he's an amazing guy versus
gone in 10 and 15 weeks like I don't
think people get it people your asset
whether you're an agency whether you
sell trinkets whether you have a website
and app what you're gonna have this like
anybody who's a business owner right now
what you can do it all by yourself like
you know and again so many of you are
solo entrepreneurs and of course you can
then you're solo entrepreneur but if you
have an organization like you know even
me and I and I very much always make the
analogy of like you know what was what
whether the calves become when LeBron
left and what are the calves become when
the Broncos back of course when you have
an a-plus hall-of-famer
on your team you make everybody better
and the organization runs on that and
and there's a difference when I'm
running when I have run Manor versus the
first couple years when I did it when I
did run Wine Library but you know in
that middle spot my dad ran the
beginning than me in the middle and
postgame like yes like yes I mean that
when you have a star quarterback you win
but it takes every every single person
in the org to achieve what you want to
achieve and more importantly when you've
been blessed and I've big blast
with a hundred a hundred fifty 615 650
employees a hundred superstars in the
making a hundred people that I can
rattle off right now on paper that I
know are going to have unbelievable
careers professionally are just
incredible people
you know business leaders just
unbelievable managers enormous Lea
scaled and just beginning the process of
their learning and more poorly what I
can bring to them over the next two to
five years what they can then blossom
into that's an intoxicating feeling and
very and very bluntly you know I'd like
to be doing business with those hundred
people now you know my goal is probably
to have 80 of them still at Vayner five
10 15 years from now but 20 of them will
go on and do different things and I'd
like to be in that ecosystem and so
providing the three minutes too many of
you are thinking so short-term you're
like yeah you took three minutes on that
but then the guy leaves and does his own
thing and then what what then what the
world continues then you could be an
investor in it then that person can
refer business to you then that person
can be your mentor II as they're
building their company and you're
helping them make it better and and then
they have an employee that's leaving and
they want a new challenge and I say well
you need to go work for my mentor like
doing the right thing is always the
right thing you know maybe I should
start having a theme and saying that in
every goddamn episode of this maybe
that's the room of this show like
putting in that 180 seconds is always
ROI positive
hey one more yeah how are you when when
I'm telling you with all my heart I got
another 50 in the last day 50 every day
50 like that 50 like that every day I'm
telling you someone move I got some real
I got really big news thanks man love
you bye
that would be good to have one day how I
told my mom excited about the askgaryvee
show
search engine I don't know this is I
think I'm doing like a PSA commercial in
the middle of a daily V but I'm super
fired up about it been working on it for
several months now
Aleksei big shout out to you one of the
fans and now a friend of ours from the
show it's like hey I built this thing
Zack and team have ideated it
incorporated to garyvaynerchuk.com when
you go on there it's there the words ask
Gary Vaynerchuk calm do rock do
something um
yeah basically every word that I've uh
turd in the 200-plus episodes of
askgaryvee is now searchable like crazy
I just found a snapchat reference from
episode 35 just super cool like amazing
and just um a lot of you knew this was
out and we talked about it but that was
based on the question now every answer
has been transcribed so now the full
monty of my POV is on leadership
platforms tactics
no more tweeting me or emailing me
hoping I'll answer you on a specific
question a lot of it has been answered
and now in search form and by the way
you search it it shows you if it's in
the question or the answer and then
indie-rock you don't have to film your
action is my bike you smelly have
somebody do like a screen grab you
should use your editing skills a little
bit doing you know you do it and it
actually takes you to the exact place
this you could show of the episode like
literally like to Brookside about it
hope it's a resource for you guys
this is about you know making
investments that bring value a one plus
one three situation right like brings
you guys a lot of value makes it faster
easier for you to get what you want
creates an environment where they'll be
more awareness about me because a lot of
you will share these answers and
questions just a one plus one equals
three that is the formula
work one word
good afternoon Sean it's Gary Vaynerchuk
I am well sorry I'm six minutes early
good to hear from you too brother
so we don't have a whole lot of time and
I want to bring you as much value as
possible tell me what's going on with
Sam the sandwich world and more
importantly what can I help you with
already did a red-eye to Boston I've got
a couple hours of sleep which is nice
thank God I got up I had an important
meeting business opportunity see how
that goes just banging on work in my
email and now that was enough we've got
three calls get in got a Skype interview
got a run to a client meeting with one
of my leaders Steve shoots Ben that
should be good excited about that that
I'm gonna pop out we're gonna film an
askgaryvee episode on the streets is
that could be double camera you're gonna
be doing daily be step on is gonna be
doing that I love that and that's
interesting that'll be good and then uh
and then a family dinner so you don't
see that stuff we've talked about that
in the past
I'm started I don't show as much of that
because people was like you never do
family have them I do we've decided not
to show it but then the rock will have
to hang around me and probably edit
because at 10:15 I'm a drinks meeting so
it's a real hustle
Andy you know you can do what most
people want to do and at their red eye
they go home and just kind of like relax
that day and recuperate which depending
on your body is appropriate but we all
have strengths and weaknesses one of my
strengths is my energy level no question
and I take advantage of that and so you
know your actions need to map what you
want and so I want it and so I'll put in
the work
I'm just watching them trying to figure
out some angles I'm like what are they
doing what are they wearing how are they
rolling I love watching this this is all
I give a [ __ ] about is all I care about
show me your actions kids show me your
actions
sorry ways sorry for ever doubting you
technology one human emotion zero
oh man how are you guys southerners good
to see you I'm doing well how are you
good
hey man so the wine sold really well
it's of course great really good
happy birthday court yeah high breath
that's a real big one tight cool okay
then good I'm happy I'm happy with today
how did Liz Liz and George say
- wrong well sure what's her name
Tyler's mom Johanna you see are you
serious yeah that's amazing right my my
mom's name is Tamara and your mom's name
is Johanna she likes me now or something
I'm uh my grandma back in tomorrow I'm a
middle school talking career jack yeah
you can pop out of this making his a
check in the box baby baby oh hello
Timur good to see you you're just
ambitious and I think Rick some people
yeah how dare he think he's gonna buy
the jet but I have no doubts I just
don't know what your timeline is but you
just gave me a clue yeah it's long term
man I'm super pumped to pull you know
honestly back to being addicted for the
process I actually secretly think I
sabotage myself I actually deep down if
you really want me to get kind of like
open up here a little bit I actually
think I can probably get there sooner
but I want to string it out
I love the foreplay of business I love
that understatement I mean I'm I I think
I'm gonna get there I just actually for
some reason this is my own romance and
maybe this is a flaw but it's mine and I
love it and I'm enjoying it I actually
really think I'd be happier buying the
Jets at 70 than 55 I don't I don't know
how to fully synthesize that for
everybody but I just really love the
climb
I love the climb I do I like the red-eye
I took last night
like secretly you know and listen I'm
taking care of my health and I'm cutting
out a lot of time for my family because
I don't want to have the casualties that
come along with the love of the climb I
don't want to die young from bad health
I don't want to lose my family from
being too much of workaholic so I'm
aware of the casualties but I would
suffocate if I couldn't play this game
the way I want to play well all right
talking so much for your time commodity
bye bye thanks Bry that was awesome
thank you so much love you man good luck
take care all right hey
Trung can you take my bag to the house
or maid or somebody that goes up there
yeah stepbrother
thanks for emailing today oh thank you
for replying that nice sneaks you did
that yeah as we good how was it
that's great it's used to be my dad a
sneaker lottery if Sam is just
fascinating how on earth this was a like
this is like a second that pig toes a
lot of value there's a Hackenberg right
here it's a very okay so sup this is us
yeah getting the card okay good hello
howdy y'all
there's the bars here right
what's that waiting through here up the
stairs
alright see ya where we going to rock
the lobby in the back
good to see you so long you how are you
good we're kind of in the cutback I love
it I love yes my blog you know just a
good old-fashioned 18-hour day all good
stuff good meetings some nice family
time tonight
working hard hustling trying to make it
happen one day at a time telling you
right now
this is all it's going to be
you know I can say the grind the hustle
but the reality is going to exhaust you
like you're gonna get tired of this just
telling you right now it's going to be
day in and day out and so for the ones
that come in and figure out the religion
and are able to deploy it against their
hopes and dreams and wants that's my
ambition and for the people that get
gist but are still entertained because
it's escapism the way I use the Jets
Mazel Tov I love having you I hope
you're enjoying it but forewarning the
few rokkes and get tired of it
this is what it looks like that's what
it's looked like for the last 20 years
it's just what it is it's not going to
change there may be funny moments I
might come up with clever sayings per
episode but it's a [ __ ] grind 24/7
365
for life